[Music]
Mike's a mile from FX guide.com for
Wired breaking down the tech in the
latest x-men film Days of Future past so
I think to fight mutants it's a whole
nother thing to fight mutant robots NPC
provider the future sentinels in the
film and produce the visual sequences
that helped sell these threatening
machines capable of absorbing mutant DNA
and using it in a film they do this by
using metallic scales or blades that
flare mimicking mistakes ability and her
trademark appearance transition NPCs
initial R&D idea was to take their
existing hair and fertile which allowed
for procedural animation and adapted for
the scales however after some further
development work they realized that they
needed to introduce a whole new idea the
idea of like a proxy representation for
each individual scale or became known as
follicles quite sophisticated code was
then written that allowed NPC to design
the distribution flaring and random
orientation of each of these scales or
blades or making sure that no blade
intersected with another this scale
animation which will cause ripples
across the Sentinels body was cashed out
as a point cloud and then stored as a
matrix with various parameters for
position orientation or blade ID
ultimately the Sentinels would
incorporate one hundred thousand eight
hundred and thirty five such blades
on-screen plus another 1019 moving parts
for inside their face and while
procedural animation did actually work
out rather well for controlling most of
these follicles or or blades those 1019
parts which we see when their faces
break open they all had to be animated
by hand the effects team were able to
then have the Sentinels fight sunspot
with solar flares Iseman with arctic
cold or while of course Colossus and
blink tried to make their
hybrid escape all this made the Sentinel
some of the most technically complicated
and unstoppable robots in cinema history
which of course is why the x-men needed
to go back in time in the first place to
stop them from ever being started please
subscribe for more behind the scenes
tech I'm Mike Seymour for wide
[Music]
you